in the opening scene we are introduced
to an elderly homeless man AKA hobo
traveling on a train after a while he
gets off the train and enters a city
called Hope Town which has a
graffiti-covered welcome son that reads
scum town later Hobo is seen walking on
the streets pushing a shopping cart
filled with various discarded items
during this time he encounters an
aspiring filmmaker who is recording a
street fight the filmmaker approaches
how bow and offers him 10 bucks to
participate in the fight however hobo
simply ignores him and walks away the
mobo not a bum as he reaches a bit
further he suddenly hears a distressed
voice from behind upon turning around he
sees a man named Logan whose face is
covered in blood with a manhole lid
stuck on his neck and his hands tied
Logan approaches several people in the
street seeking help claiming that
someone is pursuing him but
unfortunately nobody is willing to
assist him shortly after a modern white
car arrives Logan turns to hobo for help
but the latter disregards his plea and
continues way right then a mini truck
arrives out of nowhere and collides with
his shopping cart causing his collection
to scatter following this a man named
Drake dressed in a white suit steps out
of the truck revealing a pistol stuffed
in his waistband simultaneously Drake's
two sons slick and Ivan step out of the
modern car and label Logan as a betrayer
it is revealed that Logan is Drake's
younger brother but their relationship
is strained and broken as the crowd
watches on slick and dive and grab Logan
by his arms and drag him towards a
nearby manhole they forcefully push him
down the hole leaving his body suspended
inside while his head remains above the
ground then in a Twisted manner Drake
addresses the onlookers as if they are
part of an audience and considers Logan
as a lucky contestant He commands
everyone to witness the spectacle and
proceeds to fasten a barbed wire of
round Logan's neck connecting the other
end to the modern car after this he
orders slick to begin the show and the
latter accelerates the car at a high
speed this results in poor Logan's head
being severed from his body after the
commotion ends Drake holds the detached
head and issues a warning to everyone
saying that they could be the next lucky
contestant in his show meanwhile hobo
collects his belongings in his shopping
cart and continues wandering the streets
along the way he comes across a pawn
shop and notices a lawnmower that
captures his interest however upon
reading the price tag of 49.99 he lets
out a sigh and walks away that same
night hobo positions himself on a
pathway holding a sign that reads I am
tired need money for a lawnmower
unfortunately a group of rude teenagers
approaches him and disrespectfully spits
on his side after some time hobo spots
slick exiting his modern car and
entering a building curious he follows
the guy inside only to discover Drake's
gang members torturing and murdering
people in an arcade-like game as hobo
watches everything from a corner slick
starts to harass a young boy named Otis
who owes him money seeing this an escort
named Abby intervenes urging slick to
release Otis since he is just a child
she then proceeds to walk away but slick
persuades her to accompany him to
another room promising to pay her good
hobo who's been closely observing
Slick's actions silently follows them
once inside the room slick and Abby
start making out however they are
interrupted when a masked man enters
through the garage door he is there to
actually kidnap Abby and sell her on the
black market but fortunately hobo
arrives in the nick of time and stops
the man this anger's slick prompting him
to bring out a knife and Advance towards
hobo but Against All Odds the old beggar
knocks him out by striking him with a
bag of coins he then carries the
gangster to the police station and
tosses him onto the desk demanding the
officers arrest him not only that hobo
also insists on speaking with the police
chief so he's directed to wait in an
interrogation room shortly after a high
high-ranking police officer enters the
room hobo urges him to take strict
action against all the criminals in the
town explaining that the situation is
getting out of control the officer
acknowledges his concerns but reveals
that almost all the cops in town are
friends with Drake so going against him
is not possible saying this the officer
suddenly changes his demeanor and points
a gun at hobo at the same time Drake's
Sons also arrive at the scene and start
beating up hobo slick even carves the
word scum into his chest after this two
police officers callously discard hobo
into a garbage bin in the next scene
Abby is trying to make a deal with a guy
for the night when the injured hobo
stumbles upon her seeing his pitiful
condition she brings him to her place
and tends to his wounds she even lets
him stay at her place for the night the
following morning hobo goes to the same
filmmaker from earlier and takes up the
offer he willingly subjects himself to a
series of demeaning acts such as
smashing a glass bottle against his head
and chewing its shards once he has
earned enough money he revisits the same
pawn shop and decides to purchase the
lawnmower but suddenly a group of Three
Robbers enters the shop and takes a
woman and her baby hostage they then
threaten the shop owner to give up all
the money witnessing all this hobo
becomes really annoyed and decides to
take matters into his own hands he
angrily grabs a shotgun from a nearby
shelf and fatally shoots the robbers one
by one once the commotion is over hobo
realizes that hope town is in dire need
of Justice hence he is a change of heart
decides to buy the shotgun instead of
the lawnmower wondering what he was
going to do with that mower is going to
bug me forever from that point forward
hobo embarks on a Relentless mission to
eliminate numerous criminals starting
with the filmmaker armed with his
shotgun he continues his Crusade by
targeting a pimp a drug dealer and a
pedophile disguised as Santa Claus with
each Act he becomes a vigilante
delivering Justice to those who have
wronged the innocent news of his
courageous actions quickly spreads
throughout the city drawing the
attention of the bad guys in a fit of
anger Drake shoots the television screen
and berates his sons for allowing hobo
to escape this humiliates like a diamond
so they set out to eliminate hobo and
make their dad proud in the next scene
the brothers board a school bus and
ruthlessly Slaughter 14 children using a
flamethrower okay further display of
brutality they storm a television
station during a live broadcast and
murder the Anchorman for praising hobo
the brothers then continue the live
broadcast and issue a chilling threat to
the public they don't kill all the
homeless people in town their own
children will suffer the same fate in
response to the threat a horrifying
Massacre of the homeless population
ensues in the town with even police
officers engaging in the violence in the
midst of this commotion Abby is heading
home when she is approached by two
officers one of them decides to exploit
her for the night but she refuses his
advances in flees enraged the officer
pursues her and Corners her near a
dumpster he attempts to assault her but
just in the nick of time hobo intervenes
and shoots the officer with his shotgun
he then offers to accompany Abbey home
however a large crowd approaches them
prompting Abby to quickly devise a plan
she conceals hobo in a shopping cart
covering it with the remains of the
deceased officer the plan works and the
two manage to pass through the crowd
undetected shortly after they reach
Abby's residence and hobo finally exits
the cart to his Misfortune Otis who is
nearby spots them and promptly informs
the gangster Brothers inside Abby's
Department hobo shares his idea of
starting a lawn mowing business he wants
to get away from the violence and earn
decent money surprisingly Abby supports
his idea and agrees to help him out the
two then decide to escape Hometown and
begin a new life together however their
plans are disrupted when slick and dive
and arrive at the apartment and break
into Abby's room Ivan inflicts wounds on
hobo using his ice skate shoes while
slick pursues Abby he Corners her
against a wall but she fights back by
grabbing a Shard of glass and slashing
his face unfortunately this only anger
is slick more and in an act of Revenge
he grabs a saw and begins hurting her
neck I heard this movie was available on
Disney plus meanwhile hobo manages to
subdue Ivan by electrocuting him with an
appliance upon hearing Abby's screams he
rushes to her Aid and holds slick at gun
points the latter tries to claim his
innocence but hobo hears none of it and
shoots him in the balls amidst the
commotion Ivan regains Consciousness and
runs away but hobo has no time to pursue
to him instead he loads Abby onto his
shopping cart and rushes her to the
hospital meanwhile have fatally injured
slick contacts his father and informs
him about the situation as he ends the
call he hallucinates a burning boss in
which hobo locks him and leaves him to
die but in reality he passes away due to
severe loss of Blood on the other hand
hobo reaches the hospital and threatens
the doctor to save Abby they immediately
comply out of fear and begin the surgery
on her elsewhere Drake who Mourns the
loss of his beloved Son decides to
recruit a pair of armored demons known
as Rip and grinder collectively known as
the plague the following day Abby
regains Consciousness and finds hobo by
her side he presents her with a small
potted flower as a Keepsake and prepares
to leave Abby tries to stop him arguing
that he cannot solve all the world's
problems only with his shotgun but hobo
simply says that is all I know as he
departs he passes by the Maternity Ward
and takes him moment to speak to the
infants expressing concern for their
future in a town that's a living
nightmare he hopes that they will grow
up to become hobos with shotguns but
ones who are even better than himself
shortly after the plague breaks into the
hospital and mercilessly Slaughters the
staff members in their path upon hearing
the chaos hobo rushes back to Abby's
Ward only to be captured by the plague
they can find him in a trunk and
transport him to Drake who plans to
publicly execute him when Abby learns
that her only friend has been captured
she decides to embark on a rescue
mission her first stop is the pawn shop
where she creates her own Weapon by
combining an ax with Hobo's shotgun and
transforming a lawnmower into a
makeshift Shield as she prepares to
depart a crowd confronts her and
questions whether she is homeless they
are still following the orders of Drake
and are looking to eliminate all the
hobos in town however this only annoys
Abby prompting her to passionately
address the crowd delivering a lengthy
speech advocating for the rights of
homeless people the scene then cuts to
the streets where Drake announces his
brand new show to the gathered crowd the
plague grabs hobo fastens a manhole lit
around his neck and drops him into a pit
for execution exactly how they did to
Logan but before the process can begin
Abby arrives at the scene and holds Ivan
hostage she demands Drake to let her
friend go but surprisingly the
cold-hearted gangster kills his son
himself calling him a disappointment
after this grinder goes after Abby well
rip prepares to execute hobo this
creates a very tense situation as the
crowd watches on fortunately Against All
Odds Abby manages to kill grinder using
her Advanced weapon she also manages to
cut the rope tying Hobo's neck saving
him from decapitation in the nick of
time in the aftermath an enraged Drake
captures Abby and brutally cuts off her
hand using the lawnmower Shield but
despite the injury she retaliates and
repeatedly stabs Drake with her exposed
arm bone she then rushes to free hobo
who then aims his shotgun at rip forcing
him to retreat following this hobo
approaches Drake and names his shotgun
at him at the same time the police
arrive at the scene and demand that hobo
surrender his weapon however the
townspeople who have been inspired by
Abby's courage align themselves with
hobo and turn their firearms towards the
police the support hobo ultimately
brings an end to Drake's Reign by
blowing off his head this prompts the
police to shoot hobo in the townspeople
in return opened fire on the police the
movie ends as all the people are killed
on the Spot while Abby's screams are
heard in the background
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching